[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild sie ist dann zum Wagen gewangt
schon Blut verschmiert und hat nur noch
gestammelt das ist hier alles kein Spaß
mehr ist dann
zusammengebrochen das ist die Stimme von
Bildreporter Frank Schneider er war
damals beim turbulenten Prozess dabei
als die Mörder der 14-jährigen Philis
vor Gericht standen hallo und schön dass
ihr dabei seid hier bei Tatort
Deutschland ich bin Mirko Kasimir und
bei mir ist die wunderbare Tony haer
danke Mirko was für ein
Intro für unseren heutigen Fall gehen
wir zurück ins Jahr 2004 es ist Samstag
der 29 mai Pfingstwochenende die
14-Jährige Philis verbringt den Abend
mit ihrer ein Jahr jüngeren Freundin
Nicole phis ist zwar noch sehr jung aber
nachts bereits viel
unterwegs am Abend lernen die Mädchen
auf dem Gelände einer Tankstelle im
nordreheinwestfälischen lüdenschid zwei
Männer kennen den 20 Jahre alten Baris
und seinen 17 Jahre alten Kumpel fatich
beide kommen aus dem benachbarten neuen
Rade Bildreporter Frank Schneider
schildert uns die Begegnung wie folgt
das war eine Zufallsbekanntschaft das
war man hing wohl so an dem ich meine an
dem Schnellrestaurant bei McDonald's
hing man zusammen rum und
hat dort immer ja sich getroffen und die
jungen Männer die schon Auto hatten dann
fuhr man halt zusammen rum und war dann
eben unterwegs und hier war es eben auch
so dass man die jungen Mädels
mitgenommen hat man ist dann wohl zu
einer talspar
gefahren und dann soll folgendes
passiert sein die vier fahren zu einer
Talsperre das jetzt für mich z.B als
Hamburgerin etwas ungewöhnlich aber in
dem Fall gar nicht denn Lüdenscheid
liegt im Sauerland und in der Umgebung
gibt es eben zahlreiche
zalsperren und da sei es dann zu Sex
gekommen so erzählte es später der
20jährige Baris zwischen ihm und der
14-jährigen Philis an diesem Abend
kommen die beiden also frisch zusammen
weiteres zu dieser Nacht ist nicht
bekannt nächstes Treffen es ist
Pfingstsonntag der 30 mai 2004 die vier
haben sich in Köln verabredet um den Tag
zusammen zu verbringen für den Abend
planen die beiden jungen Männer mit den
Mädchen ein disobesuch in Hagen doch zu
dem Discobesuch kommt es nicht auf dem
Weg dorthin halten sie auf einem
Wanderparkplatz in der Nähe der A45 bei
Hagen Grund für den ungeplanten Stopp
soll folgendes gewesen sein Frank
Schneider dann hat es im Auto wohl ein
Streitgespräch gegeben weil sie
ungeschützten Verkehr hatten hat sie ihn
aufgezogen sie hatten alle türkischen
Migrationshintergrund und hat sie ihn
aufgezogen vielleicht sei sie ja
schwanger und dann können er das ja mal
seiner Familie erklären wenn das so wäre
und hat ihn da irgendwie provoziert
warum weiß man nicht genau die beiden
diskutieren sagen wir eher sie streiten
heftig und das wahrscheinlich auch
lautstark sie wirft ihm vor dass er sich
in Köln nach anderen Mädchen umgeschaut
habe und nennt ihn und ich
kann mir gut vorstellen dass es an
diesem Punkt völlig eskaliert ist einen
Tag später es ist pfingstmtag gegen
Abend in werdoh die Kleinstadt ist 6 km
von Baris und fatis Heimatort entfernt
hier gehen die beiden auf die
Polizeiwache und sagen wir sind die
Mörder aber noch mal zurück zum
Parkplatz einen Tag vorher dem
Pfingstsonntag auf der A45 bei Hagen
Baris geht mit Philis zum Kofferraum die
beiden diskutieren dann holt er ein
Messer
hervor später Schildt Baris folgende
Version vor Gericht ihr sagt aus dass
während des Streits Philis irgendwann
zum Kofferraum gegangen sei und ein
Messer rausgeholt habe sie habe ihn
angegriffen und dann habe er sich in
Notwehr verteidigt was der Richter davon
hielt erzählt uns Frank Schneider bei 30
Messerstichen hat der Richter natürlich
auch gesagt das ist somit die
schlechteste Ausrede die er je gehört
hat er soll zu seiner Tat stehen also er
versuchte die Situation dann auch noch
rumzudrehen vor Gericht das war schon
mehr als
erbärmlich und das ist in der Nacht auf
pfingstmag wirklich passiert war es hat
dann auf diesem einsamen Wanderparkplatz
aus dem Kofferraum ein 15 cm langes
Fleischermesser genommen was wohl im
Kofferraum lag das war wohl der Wagen
seines Vaters und hat dann sofort auf
sie eingestochen und die 13jährige
Freundin Nicole hat das ja alles
beobachtet konnte ihr aber nicht helfen
Waris sticht 30 mal mit einem 15 cm
langen Fleischermesser auf phis ein der
Staatsanwalt wird später wortwörtlich
sagen Baris habe sie abgestochen pH
Freundin Nicole sitzt im Auto neben
fahtig und muss alles mit ansehen sie
schildert später dass ich die bereits
schwer verletzte phis blutverschmiert
zum Wagen geschleppt habe mit den Worten
dass dies alles hier kein Spaß mehr ist
Philis liegt bereits im Sterben aber da
ist noch Nicole sie hat alles mit
angesehen Baris und fatig beraten nun
kurz was mit ihr geschehen soll Frank
Schneider über den weiteren Verlauf und
dann hat der Haupttäter Baris
schließlich seinen Freund der dabei war
17 Jahre alt gezwungen jetzt du sie
töten so nach dem Motto die ist Zeugin
du hängst hier mit drin du musst das
jetzt auch machen und der hat dann unter
dem Druck des ganzen im warn mehr oder
weniger auf das jüngere Opfer
eingestochen kann ich mich auch noch
erinnern dass der Richter damals auch
gesagt hat dass das so unglaublich wä
wenn er schon so eine Wahnsinnstat
begeht im Streit im Affekt aber dann
eben noch das jüngere Mädchen zu töten
eine 13jähge einfach nur weil sie mit
dem Auto sitzt und man kann sich gar
nicht vorstellen welche Ängste sie
durchlebt hat auch als
Zeugin sagt sp er habe als Nicole
bereits am Boden lag ein oder zweimal
mit einem zweiten Messer außerhalb des
Autos auf sie eingestochen anschließend
habe Baris Nicole ebenfalls
angegriffen zusammen attackieren die
beiden Männer ihr zweites Opfer so lange
bis sie überzeugt sind dass Nicole auch
tot ist insgesamt sollen sie ungefähr 20
mal auf die 13-Jährige eingestochen
[Musik]
haben es ist nachts es ist dunkel der
Parkplatz liegt einsam abgeschieden an
einer Landstraße Nicole stellt sich tot
sie ist schwerst verletzt Baris und
fatich fliehen Nicole schleppt sich noch
zur Straße sie kann ein herannahendes
Auto
stoppen der Fahrer alarmiert polizei und
Rettungskräfte und wie durch ein Wunder
überlebt Nicole die Täter die Ahnen
davon aber nichts sie erfahren davon
erst aus den Medien und stellen sich
Frank Schneider erinnert sich das werde
ich auch nie vergessen das schon sehr
ungewöhnlich war offenbar war das Druck
von der Familie sie müssen sich wohl
anvertraut haben bzw soweit ich mich
erinnern kann waren eben auch noch
Blutspuren am Körper das ist natürlich
bei so einer Vielzahl von Messerstichen
auch erwartbar und dann haben sie sich
schließlich gestellt aber nicht weil sie
glaube ich so räumütig waren in dem
Moment sondern weil der Druck so groß
war und ihn ja klar war nicole hat
überlebt und sie wird gegen uns Aussagen
und sie wusste gar nicht die genau Namen
der beiden weil man sich ja erst am Tag
vorher kennengelernt hat aber aufgrund
der Beschreibung und des Autos wä man
sowieso auf sie gekommen und beide sind
dann sofort in Untersuchungshaft
gegangen es ist februar
2005 erster Verhandlungstag und an
diesem Tag kochen die Emotionen so
richtig hoch phis Mutter hat im Vorfeld
der Verhandlung beruhigungsspritzen
bekommen doch hört gut zu was jetzt
passiert hier kommen die Details der
Prozess Auftakt war sehr spektakulär ich
war damals selber vor Ort und kann mich
noch erinnern wie die Mutter des Opfers
also von Philis als die beiden
Angeklagten reingeführt wurden völlig
ausgerastet ist es auf den Tisch
gesprungen das sah aus als könnte die
schweben dass ich weiß bis heute nicht
wie so schnell auf den Tisch gekommen
ist ist dann über den Richtertisch
gelaufen quer durch den Saal und ist
dann einfach gesprungen auf den Täter
drauf und hat gesagt er hatte ziemlich
hervorstehende Augen hat immer
Froschauge genannt Froschauge ich ich um
ist dann auf ihn losgegangen der
damalige Oberstaatsanwalt ist dazwischen
gegangen zwei Beamte des Wachdienstes
sind dazwischen gegangen die wurden alle
leicht verletzt und sie ist wirklich wie
von Sinnen auf den losgegangen das hat
aber keine strafrechlichen Konsequenzen
am Ende gehabt weil er der Angeklagte
auf eine Strafanzeige verzichtet hat und
aufgrund der psychischen
Ausnahmesituation dass es hier um den
Mord an ihrer 14jährigen Tochter
ging nach der Verlesung der Anklage
vertagt der Vorsitzende Richter den
Prozess den beiden jungen Männern wird
Totschlag versuchter Mord und
gefährliche Körperverletzung vorgeworfen
der emotionale Ausbruch von Felix Mutter
bleibt ohne Folgen der Angeklagte
verzichtet auf eine Strafanzeige und das
Gericht sieht hier eine psychische
Ausnahmesituation gegeben die Mutter
selbst entschuldigt sich noch vor
Gericht und beteuert es würde ihr Leid
tun sie könne sich gar nicht richtig
erinnern an das was geschehen
ist am 17 februar 2005 wird der Prozess
fortgesetzt
unter besonderen
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen unser Reporter
über das Strafmaß die sind beide
verurteilt worden war es z höstrafe von
10 Jahren sein mitangeklagter Komplize 9
Jahre und das ist ja nach
Jugendstrafrecht nicht mehr möglich
gewesen beide sind als relativ unreif
eingeschätzt worden und trotz ihres
Alters von 20 und 17 also der 17jähri so
heranwachsen oder Jugendlicher aber auch
der Baris als 20jähriger ist nach
Jugendstrafrecht verurteilt worden und
das eben mehr als 10 Jahre so gut wie
nicht möglich verurteilt werden Baris
und ftig wegen vollendeten Todschlags
weil dem ja wie wir anfangs erwähnt
haben ein Streit vorausgegangen sein
soll also die angeblichen Provokation
wodurch sich das dann sozusagen
hochgeschaukelt hat unser Experte in dem
Fall Frank Schneider kann das nicht ganz
nachvollziehen was aber eben war es war
auch versuchter Mord denn Nicole das
muss man einfach so sagen die sollte
sterben einfach nur weil sie dabei war
weil sie Zeugin war und deshalb soll sie
weg Baris lässt über seine Anwälte
erklären dass er phis nicht mit Absicht
töten wollte er werde sein Leben nun mit
seiner Tat und seiner Schuld verbringen
müssen ihm gehe es sehr schlecht er sei
sehr angespannt wegen der
Haftbedingungen und dem
Prozess auch Nicole ist als Zeugin im
Prozess anwesend sie hat diesen Horror
nur knapp überlebt und welche Namen sie
ihr restliches Leben mit sich trägt das
will man sich gar nicht vorstellen nicht
nur war ihre Jugend mit dieser Tat Sch
artig vorbei sie hat dazu auch noch ihre
beste Freundin verloren und mit diesem
Trauma muss sie irgendwie
weiterleben und damit sind wir am Ende
unseres heutigen Falles wir danken euch
dass ihr mit dabei wart und freuen uns
wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal wieder
einschaltet und wie immer wenn ihr
Kritik Anregungen oder fallvorschläge
habt oder uns einfach nur eure Meinung
mitteilen wolld dann schreibt uns gerne
eine E-Mail eine Nachricht bei Whatsapp
oder eine DM bei Instagram die Infos
dazu findet ihr in den Show nototes
recherchiert haben wir den Fall mit
Artikeln vom Spiegel dem Stern und der
reinischen Post und wir bedanken uns bei
Bildreporter Frank Schneider für seine
Statements bis zum nächsten mal euer
Milko und eure
Tony die hat diese Folge von T
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei tatout
Deutschland